Hello Freak bitches.
How does the Academy Awards work?
I don't know how it works,
but I would assume it's a bunch of people that are experts in the business.
We're in the business.
Good idea,
Joe.
That's a great idea though.
That's different.
The Weinstein sizes.
Oh Man.
Crazy right documentary and an open secret watched that shit.
I keep hearing about the open secret about,
it's about politics.
It's about Hollywood managers who manage kids.
It's a racket.
Ma'Am.
Did you hear the term kid from strange and these kids?
Dude,
strange things.
Strange stranger things.
He date just left.
He just left his manager and they're alleging sexual abuse.
They'll just let their agency,
if you could find that Owen bench truly here kid.
Oh yeah.
Just put it on his uh,
Instagram today because Olin is been taken a lot of heat online because he said
that a three year old kid shouldn't be fucking transgender.
And people giving him a hard time seeing he's a bigot.
Like are you out of your fucking mind when you're top three transgender show
stranger things act or dropped agent because of sec accused of sexual assault.
Disney star fall suit.
Jesus Christ.
This is nuts.
Watch an open secret and they tell you,
they go through,
do they pick their people?
It's on.
It's for free I think on Vimeo.
Yeah.
You can go watch it for free.
Just secret stuff.
Youtube or some genius.
You know what a Sturgill Simpson told me.
He said the same thing exists in music,
in music.
There's a bunch of pedals and pet rap music as well as entertainment business
all the way through music that this was,
this was about music and movies and TV.
It's about the whole women,
women and kids.
Most of the,
and sometimes dudes,
you know,
Terry Cruz said that he was attacked,
well not attacked.
Some dude grabbed,
grabbed his dick in front of this white famous dude,
grabbed his dick.
You know what I sold that.
Um,
who was that fucking big time football player that was in that weird movie with
John Travolta?
Howie long,
Howie Long said the exact same shit was happening to him.
Perhaps Dick guys were coming after how we long guys were,
were propositioning him,
trying to tell him this is what you have to do to make it in the movie business
suck Dick [inaudible] who else?
It happened to haul Cogan same thing.
Yes,
coating up all the Logan got proposition by high level movie person that told
him this is how the game is played and did he do it and that's why he's not in
movies or why are you using today?
We got guys who are killing it.
Super Skeptical hip.
What do have been coming out now?
Donald Sterling.
Look at these beautiful black bodies.
What does that,
it's something that I heard about before he got in trouble that this is why a
lot of players didn't want to play for him because he was known to bring people
down in the locker room to look at his players showering and whatnot.
Just like,
why is everyone so fucking creepy?
Be Cool,
be cool man.
Hey Man,
my idea about we go back to your kids,
watch your motherfucking,
don't let your kids be around.
Weird fucking agency taking.
Don't let your kids get into acting.
Do not let your kids get into,
does it ever worked out?
Well,
you know the other thing is like look at what happened with that uh,
Sandusky guy.
That guy was taking care of kids.
Like his whole thing was like,
hey,
I do charitable work with children.
You know,
I do charitable work and I take care of them.
Are Kids.
Yeah.
I'm just,
I'm just all about helping kids.
It's all about helping kids.
They're our future.
How about Calvin?
Went to summer camp does sucked my counselor,
I think he got jacked off his friend guys dig.
So
it's funny cause it's Callan.
What's,
I'm not advocating any of the famous guys,
a famous in the UK who died and then they found out what does that,
what's that guy's name?
A shimmy.
Seville.
What'd he do?
Like he was super famous.
Super famous.
He had a big talk show in,
in England.
Bring Him Benny Hill.
Yeah,
that's the guy.
No shower.
No Shit.
He fucks.
Look at the picture above him.
Look at that picture above with the red glasses above with the crazy hair.
One more the,
Oh my God,
that fucking guy you should be slapped.
Imagine that guy putting his dick in your mouth.
Is there a documentary on him?
Yeah.
What's that call?
Cause they,
she kept this a secret for a long time because this guy was like a,
uh,
a big star over there.
Look at his motherfucking team.
Kept the secret like the media,
the people that occurred with him,
like everyone knew that.
Like what about the rose?
We'll go to that.
Go back to that.
What about law enforcement in the UK?
You know what I mean?
The roos knew Jimmy Seville.
Seville is that,
I say it's Seville.
Documentary is a horrible misstep.
Oh,
Louis Theroux is awesome.
I doubt that he fucked anything up that kind of make some of the best fucking
documentary's going.
He's a monster.
It's probably some,
yeah,
someone was a hater.
Who exactly.
That is so heavy haters out there.
And think about that.
Think about Don
don notes.
Sub No ne.
Yeah.
Suddenly,
fuck yeah man.
There's a lot of Jimmy Savile gropes teenager in newly released Louis Theroux
footage.
Ugh.
Powerful show.
Have you seen the stuff that Joe Biden,
Joe Biden,
the former vice president do?
There's videos on him like at the White House and taking pictures with kids.
Did you know looking at,
we've seen that.
Really?
I haven't seen,
have you seen that shit?
He's like,
he's groping them and shit.
It just think he's super awkward with this guy's running.
When you're untouchable,
when there's no way you're going to get busted for anything.
Murdered child molestation.
Did he don't give a fuck.
He just don't give a fuck who you are.
You grabbing my kid anywhere appropriate.
There's a lot.
And he's like,
dude,
I got sick bastard.
It looks like we said there must there and just pulled her secret.
Yeah.
Shit.
The problem is you've taken like a screenshot because I've heard the audio.
You could hear that.
What he says to these,
he say creepy ass shit.
Like get like what?
Like do they just keep,
just keep,
he's taking pictures.
All these kids and he's just like,
ah.
I just whispering in their ear and Oh,
you're beautiful.
Gruffy of a big government creep.
Oh,
video of this.
These are stills.
But there's actually video this shit,
and this is by the way,
what you've seen in public,
right?
Yeah.
He don't care that don't give a shit nuts not to deals and care.
It's just,
that's a small version of probably what he's like behind closed doors.
If you're a big Hollywood act or maybe you're not and you didn't get sexually
harassed or like pissed off right now,
know what I'm saying?
Like what the fuck?
If you're an actress and you worked with Harvey Weinstein,
he never tried to suck his dick.
You like,
what you,
what's wrong with me?
Yeah.
You ugly.
Fuck is wrong with my face.
They're really going after him.
That seems weird.
It doesn't seem weird,
dude.
You're going after a guy's entire business.
Here's the thing,
he's one of many.
There's gotta be like a bunch of people that ran their business that way.
Weinstein,
they say like in Hollywood,
like just like,
oh no.
Yeah,
it's about time you got caught.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Everyone knew this one knew it was in his contract.
The way he had his contract set up was like they had a certain amount of money
that he would have to pay if he had a sexual harassment claim against him.
It was like,
it was a thing for him.
Like he had so many claims that's like first offense was a hundred thousand
second offense.
My 250003rd defense was $750,000 for third.
Fourth offense was a million.
Who would get it written into his fucking contract?
Come here,
Max.
His contract with the Weinstein company,
like his own Merrimack to explain that contract like they'd have to,
he'd have to pay a hundred thousands yes.
Could,
they're protecting themselves.
Ras,
when they signed him,
they go,
okay.
The first time he fucked with one of these guns can be 100,000 second time and
see it's not shit.
Yes.
I mean,
he was prominent.
It was such a huge,
it was so known of what he would do.
And look,
even Quentin Tarantino said that he did it to his ex girlfriend quieter and Tito
said he knew about it.
Yeah,
he did it to Mira Sorvino.
Dude.
And could Harvey Weinstein get any fucking uglier?
[inaudible] young ass wise.
So he looks like a troll.
He know what he looks like is a sexual Predator and a Harvey Weinstein movie.
Correct?
Like it.
Like it was a shitty lifetime movie.
Like,
come on,
let's do a little bit on that.
Legs unrealistic.
He's hideous.
I think.
You know what I,
it's so bad.
Look at the girls that he's harassing them.
Most of them bitches are fucking trash anyways.
You know what I mean?
No,
no,
no.
Here's what he says.
Christ distracted.
What about the kids?
Fuck them bitches.
What about the kids that's going on?
I don't focus on that.
Those girls are trash,
just actress.
But here's the question.
Here's the problem was what Whitney told me when he says yes,
she,
she knows her shit.
What she said is she,
there's a lot of girls that aren't saying a word because they did fuck them and
they caught them for parts.
They fucked him for like editing,
of course,
did them for a lot of things that Donald Trump,
that's the rumor.
But that this is like a standard thing that Weinstein would do and women agreed
to it because he was a power from mother fucker that could get the world hold
up.
However many,
whatever,
50 girls that come out with claims against him,
he's probably fucked 5,000 who aren't coming out.
I think that's probably a real number and ridiculously hot girls we all know
about now what?
I suck his dick to be the next Batman.
Yeah,
probably,
man,
Donald's,
Ronnie,
Darren,
you don't focus on the kids.
Here we go.
Well that's,
that's certainly an issue,
but it's an Rv,
but then that's kind of fucked for parts.
You know what I mean?
Don't you remember Brian Singer?
I remember that guy who is the x men guy.
That guy got busted because some 17 year old boy was saying that he got used by
him at a party and they would pass them around to all their friends and they had
all these buoys.
What guy?
Bryan singer and the guy goes,
no,
no x men.
Oh my bed x files is talking about the guy with the x files.
No X men.
Right?
The famous director.
Yeah,
that's the guy.
He's in the movie.
Oh,
an open secret.
I'm sure it's about,
it's about him.
Hold up.
He would and he was just some dude like the director here he goes,
look at that.
The sad turn behind La Party scene that took down Brian Singer.
Like he would have all these like young boys with them and there's a picture of
them at a pool.
It is fucking hilarious.
There's drop,
scroll back up.
Look at this picture like look at him and all these young boys.
The Tim on the right.
It's him above with the glasses or no,
the one with the arm wrapped around us.
Like yellow bathroom for the glasses.
See Him with his arm wrapped around.
Got You wrapped around that boy.
Put his hand on that guy.
The kid's chest.
What the kid looks like.
He's off 16 right.
So there's a picture of him at a party that he threw at his place.
That is hilarious because that party has all these young twinks in a pool and
the pool's lights are red.
Like,
like they butt fuck so much that they just bled out and the whole pool became
red right there.
Look at that.
Tell me what doesn't look like that.
Fuck man.
That's party of Brian's at all.
Uh,
are they all under age?
No,
probably not,
but we'll does that.
Nothing's wrong with,
if I,
anyone know how many of them were,
but some of them apparently were under age.
Holy Shit.
It just seems like that's a cock fest.
If you're a young boy and you're trying to be an actor in Hollywood or a singer,
how are you going to avoid that shit?
Look at these fucking parties.
All these guys that hands on each other.
Well,
if the thing about gay guys,
right,
it's like a lot of gay guys like guys that look younger,
they like,
like cute guy.
Twinks they don't,
they call them twinks.
You don't have a lot of hair,
which really funny because a nd what the fuck's his name from?
Uh,
the guy from a,
that runs bravo.
What does that guy,
oh,
Andy Collins.
Yeah,
that guy.
He got in trouble for saying twink and he's gay.
Really?
Yeah,
he's getting shit.
He's awesome at doing everything.
Twink is like a thin hairless like young,
young skin,
young shape kids.
They call them twins guy.
Sorry Darren till walking into the octagon.
Let's actually watch this fight cause he,
I get creeped out.
We all have kids and I feel after all the time it makes,
it makes me sick.
Jesus Christ,
man.
Yeah.
Well Corey Feldman apparently has been talking a lot about it too.
Not Adam.
It's crazy.
But the question is why is he crazy?
Is he crazy?
Because he was molested him.
It doesn't say he doesn't name names,
but maybe he will.
If someone said 80% of kids in Hollywood or in the entertainment business have
had some kind of run in with,
uh,
someone tried to molest him,
would you believe it?
Yes.
80%.
I would say a day.
I don't know.
I don't want to give out crazy numbers.
I would say a large number.
I wouldn't be cycling Olympic team
because I think there's legitimate agents.
This is what we've been gentlemen,
managers and I think Disney has a pretty great record.
Probably just never getting worse.
They're probably legit,
but those ones don't get any work.
It just seems like it celebrates,
like they just hook each other up and they're just looking for,
uh,
they're only going to know.
Some of them do.
There's definitely predators that are organized.
Definitely no one ever made any advances at you,
Joe?
No,
never.
Nothing.
Not like,
Hey,
come give me a better comic.
John said he got molested in Hollywood when Alex Jones,
Alex Jones talked about that,
correct.
[inaudible]
okay.